I Merlin I'm here to talk about a
project of continuum analytics which is
called dined so the other talk is sorry
yeah sure so the title to talk or I can
use a microphone okay so to speak louder
so the patella talk is dying enabling
complex analytics across the language
barrier and one of the things that dined
has been engineered to do is to be a
kind of numpy like library but an enough
for pipe just for Python but also for
other things like our JavaScript and
Julia potentially so that's the swear
this title comes from and so I split
this talk to two parts the first is um
vo what let me just that screen yup okay
so the first is the what and why I've
dined it so that's going to be dined at
a high level we're going to talk about
you know why it exists why we're doing
it what we're doing and the second is
I'm just going to show you some code
snippets of the kinds of things it can
do so what is dined died names to be a
modern library for array oriented
computing okay great what does that even
mean so what that means is dying is a
library it's not a language so I mean
many of us use arrays many of us I think
use numpy I mean kind I'm just curious
how many people have used numpy
everybody yeah exactly and so we do
those kinds of calculations numpy is you
know quite old now it's at least 20
years old ostrava setteth started the
orange of it were really 1997 and it's
got a lot of sort of flaws and sort of
other things we'd like to do that would
be nice we enabled so dying is a library
like numpy that we hope will help people
do these things it is not a language
into itself that is something you sort
of a solution like Julia which is also
very good but but a bit different so
this helps do computation with arrays
and I said it's a modern array oriented
library what I really mean there is that
we're using software engineering
practices from today trying to solve
problems that people have had for a
while
I mean I don't know if you've ever
looked at I'm sure most people here
haven't looked at the num pie source
code but I mean even Travis would it
would agree with this that it perhaps
wasn't as best as well engineered as it
could have been at the time so what is
died really diamond is really a
collection of three things it's a
fully-featured type system along with a
callable like function object together
with an array container engineered in
c++ and bound to dynamic bound to
dynamic languages like Python so we have
type objects we have a callable object
and we have an array container and we've
written these completely in C++ and then
we want to bring in other dynamic
languages so before I go any further I
just want to be clear out what dined is
not dined is not numpy two point oh
whatever that may mean so numpy is
really good at what it was designed to
do originally which is basically
computations with broadcasting and sort
of striped bass manipulation is
extremely good at that particular thing
and you won't get a lot of improvement
on those particular areas it's the other
areas which which some other tools like
dying and at the other controls the
Charles we're talking about where we
might see improvements and numpy is the
kind of thing that may not even be
replaceable I mean Fortran you know it's
still extremely widely used and it's
very old dined is not a jit for Python
that's number so if you have arbitrary
Python code and you wanna make it faster
you should look at the number that's
something that Travis just talked about
and this may not mean much to perhaps
this audience benign is not something
like it's not a c++ library like boost
multi array it's not template based its
dynamic so we do use templates but there
are hidden detail but the two users you
will only ever manipulate dynamic
objects okay so you may you know you may
think it's 2016 right why write another
a library and the answer is as I said
because there are problems that are not
being otherwise solved so let me give
you some examples so one example is
missing data so if you use something
like are you can have data which it may
or may not be present it may be optional
you something like Julia them and
similar thing which is a nullable type
why can't we have something like this in
Python numpy there's a this causative
master race which is kind of like
halfway house for this it's not you know
there is overhead related to these
master race and numpy is not always
consistent with how it treats them and
it they're not really stored in the best
way possible so that we really should
have a missing data solution in Python a
lot of data scientists would like
something like that this is something
that's been discussed for years I mean
if you look at the dump I mailing list
you can find I kid you not like 100
email thread about this in 2011 which
just went on forever about the different
ways to do this and then no one did
anything so dying this is one reason
don't exist of many one of many reasons
is that this is what something that
we've implanted and I that does work
today so if you want an array container
with a you know proper proper missing
data semantics you can find it there
here's another example variable length
strings numpy can't represent strings of
different lengths well it can represent
strengths of a fixed length if you want
to have a raise of you know strings of
only size for it can do that if you want
a raise where strings may be different
lengths it can only do that through
Python objects so that's really not
great and I can show and an example here
I've shown is a suppose I have you know
an array of strings of say length for
and I create it using the numpy size
strength size 40 type I do a copy of
that that takes two microseconds per
loop if I try and do it with variable
leg strings and just do a copy it takes
40 microseconds per loop so you're
getting like a factor of 20 slow down
just trying to use variable length
strengths in number that shouldn't be
the case our array container should be
able to support variable length strings
efficiently that's strings are very
common thing that people want to do so
that's another thing that we've put into
dined that we feel as a problem that
people have faced another example is
custom pipes the numpy d types are too
primitive so they're you know they're
good for representing extremely basic
things like floats or integers but there
are how do you represent something like
Oracle data categoricals are just you
know you have a variable and it may take
one of a preset to find a number of
values or what about something like a
ragged array what about it so in that
case my dimensions may be of the way of
different sizes I mean I may not be
operating in some sort of square cube I
might be it might be jagged or GPU data
it would be nice to be able to you know
naturally be able to represent these
things in numpy without having to like
rewrite numpy for so because if your
user you don't have that option another
example is we should be able to define
overloads on numpy functions you know if
you're using a programming language like
C or C++ or you know or Julia or many
other things you can very naturally
write a function which operates on a
particular set of types why can't we do
that in numpy and that is as francis
string concatenation you might want to
overload the + operator to to combine
two strings it's a very natural thing to
do that happens in many languages but we
can't do that with something like numpy
and that is again something that we've
tried to solve and dined and my last
example here would be that a lot of
times we just don't want to use Python a
lot of time we do obviously Python is
great and if it's the right thing to use
at the time you should do so but you may
just you know it may be easier to
express your computation in our or you
may just really need to work with the
C++ level for whatever reason I mean I
mean programming is really about
expressive tivity so you should go to
the language where your data is and
where you can express the computation
the easiest and and I names to be that
solution where you can have a common way
to represent data and functions across
languages right so for general traits
have dined and now I'm going to talk
about a little bit is I feel dining is
expressive generic extendable and
pluggable and i'm going to give you
specific examples of how it is so so
expressive so actually Travis had a very
summer slide here deines type system is
something called data shape and data
shape is actually the type system shared
across most of the place ecosystem with
continuous various other projects and
this is a structured data description
language the key difference from
something like numpy is that the
dimensions and the d-type are combined
into the type
so whereas number has the shape and the
d-type we've just combine them all
together so I have examples here so for
instance we might have dimension type
which we call bar which means variable
size dimension and it may have a d-type
doesn't a 32-bit integer or we may have
a g-type which is a string and we may
have three of them that's the that's a
fixed dimension and we also have things
like struck types which is you know an
aggregate type with different kinds of
data and labels for what what the names
are and we can represent tabular data in
data shape with a dimension type like
bar in front of the in front of the
child type which in this case would be
something like the structure record type
so the point is that this type system is
much more expressive than we can get a
numpy and you can express a lot of a
wider variety of data that you may
encounter in the wild using it so I also
feel dimes generic so we have these
three objects i mentioned earlier which
is that we have this type is callable
and this array object and these are
simply reference count with smart
pointers and c++ and if you don't know
that means it doesn't matter that's just
it but if you do know that means that
sort of like modern C++ and these
dynamically interpret data so you can
just use these sayings you can create
them with different types you can
manipulate them and there is it's almost
like a sort of like a highly specific
and efficient dynamic object that you'd
see in Python but written in C++ and
then bindable to other languages the
types can be parametrized and the types
so you can you know very easily write a
generic thing which operates on a
particular on arrays that are a fixed
size but wherefore in this example I'm
using this T but taking a arbitrary
d-type or option which is how we
represent missing data so i can write
very generically right on an array
function which operates on anything that
is missing data and cobbles for how we
work with collar bones we which are
array functions we think about them in a
functional sense which means that we
want you to write an innermost operation
and then use predefined transforms
to get the exact rate computation you
want so maybe you want something that
does broadcasting or maybe you don't
maybe you want a reduction maybe you
want some sort of windowing function
like the kind tribe has talked about and
and the idea here is here I've shown an
example of an element wise and this is
c++ and I will show me Python and C++ or
interchangeably as we go here you can
just very simply write your innermost
array computation and then was a single
line get something that can operate on
any number of dimensions very specific
to what you want to do and I'll show
more examples of that so dine is also
extendable so types and call was our
first class objects that usually should
create directly and I've given an
example is here this is I see just a CSS
class I don't let ma come through this
in detail but the point is i'm going to
show you that it's very easy to just go
write your own custom type define you
know a few sort of standard functions
which which die needs to know about to
understand the data and do operations
with that like guys with collar balls if
you don't want to use our predefined
transforms if you really need to do
something extremely custom you can write
your own callable which knows how to
interpret and manipulate the array of a
there the array data so we're sort of
not hiding anything from the users every
tool we use internally in dined to
create dined is something that is
available to you so there's nothing
hidden know sort of layer of detail that
you can't get access to if you need it
but you most of the time you shouldn't
need it but is there if you do so dines
also pluggable I think this is something
interesting which we haven't talked
about much before dine supports plug in
libraries so we know when we were
building it we've been thinking about
you know what about if someone comes
along and maybe they're you ever maybe
they're right in games maybe they're
doing data science doesn't matter what
they're doing but they want to write
some specific call bowls or types for
their for their needs and they'd like
them to be you know propagate able to
the other languages I supports which for
instance Python is so you can write a
today you can write a dime plugin define
your custom array operations you can use
particular functions in dined for
instance md set so you write your
callable here it's f you do ND set with
the name
and the cobble there or you can do a
namespace of call boat so you can give
you know a list of collar bolts and
names and if you just did that at the
C++ level it would propagate the whole
thing to python automatically you would
not have to write any sort of custom
site on code or boost Python code or
anything so you can actually simply just
right you know these are a operations at
the C++ level and get them in Python
without any extra work so that basically
half the amount of code you have to
maintain because you have to maintain 80
sort of rappers and that's dynamic right
so this must brings you the second part
of the talk which I just want to show of
simple examples of dying in action so
I'm going to talk about the different
types of types and show you code for
them I'm going to talk about some of the
functionals and how to create different
kinds of array copied array operations
so again just to remind you and dying
the types are instances of simple
classes so if you write a class and you
can get a type or obviously you can use
all the ones that we have already
existed that way about it created and
dine like integers floats strings
different kinds of dimensions types also
can expose dynamic features to erase so
the idea here is that you should never
ever have to subclass a diner ray which
you can always just propagate behavior
to it using types as you can propagate
methods through the erasing types you
can define how the data is interpreted
using types so an example here is
something like complex numbers which
would define properties dot real damage
which are if you know the view is their
views on on the data and you can also
defined a function like college and that
can all be done dynamically and you can
do this for your own types and types can
also be abstract and dined so you can
have kinds that match a you know a whole
family of types like int or scalar or
fixed which matches dimensions or any
which matches anything and you can also
they're also patterns so if you want to
write as I showed a few examples earlier
so you might want to write a data shape
which is a fixed time some particular
d-type but it's parameterize don t you
can do that the example the last example
I have here is that's what a callable
signature looks like in died you can
take any argument you can actually also
take keywords but and you can also write
this up in this
sort of abstract notation if you want or
you can write it very specifically with
the exact types if you want Dinah also
has metadata and data so the metadata in
dined is something like the strides
numpy it is what you use to describe the
data so it's a bit lower level than the
data shape so it's maybe actually is
like a low level data shape and we but
the difference here is we've generalized
it so that rather than just be about the
strides it can describe other things so
you might have some particular tuple so
you might have you know a tuple which is
an int afloat and a string so there
you'd put the bite offsets into the
metadata you wouldn't do that dine does
that but is there you might actually be
representing a pointer and you'd put
some of the information about that into
the metadata or in this ragged array
dimensions I've talked about earlier
there's other different eyes of metadata
so the point is that the metadata is a
generalization of how we describe the
data beyond just the Strider de protein
numpy and array data is also kula b'lore
allocatable and custom memory spaces and
we've actually done this just for GPUs
you can we just do this sort of
generically but for so we have a way to
talk about data which is in a different
memory space requires custom operations
so and that fits very naturally with the
CUDA model right so just some simple
examples of code here so these are
fundamental types so just you know
showing you how to create an integer
which or a string or a float these are
very natural things that you do or the
last example here which is a string so
which is the variable length string I
talked about earlier which dinosaur
natively supports we also have dimension
types and in dined there are two basic
dementia types the first is a fixed
dimension that's sort of what you'd
expect from numpy so it's a fixed size
it can't change and it represents that
and the second is a variable size
dimension so in the first example here
I'm creating a 3d size 3 array of n 32 s
and in the second example I'm creating a
2d array which is just a 2 by 3 array so
it's not that exotic and then the third
example which is a little bit exotic I'm
creating a variable size dimension array
so the inner dimension here is VAR and
you
notice that I'm initializing it with
three lists the first list is one two
three the second list is 45 and the
third list is six right so that does not
have uniform dimensions at all and I can
represent that so naturally and operate
on that naturally so I think that's also
something that people have sort of
wanted to do to use for a while but
there may not have been an appropriate
solution in the numpy space we can all
support aggregate types so these are
just things like to boost instructs and
again this is the kind of these are the
kinds of things that come a lot come up
a lot if you're doing data science so in
the first example I'm creating a array
of just a tuple so into floating a pool
and in the second example I'm creating a
struct which is just like a tuple but
it's got names for the members so I'm
creating a pool and in turn a string
with certain names and you can operate
you can access them using those names
and with a tuple you access them using
the index so 0 1 or 2 and we also have
missing missing data represented using
an option type and so here we use the
question mark in front of the d-type to
sing it to indicate option asst and in
the first example I'm creating a array
of size 3 and using none to it to pass
Python indicates missing us using the
non value and dine understands is as na
which is sort of the same sort of
semantics our users if you're familiar
with that and what we do which is
different from something like pandas is
that we represent the missing data using
sentinel values which are specific to
the particular type so pandas will just
typically convert everything to float
and then represented using nons but in
dying do we actually have you know an
integer based solution or string based
solution or whatever and that can extend
very naturally to custom types as well
we also have symbolic types so in dined
we have as I said we can have variables
like T to represent a parametrized type
we have ellipses which can represent any
number of dimensions like in the second
example and we also have we have any
which is just a you know
and are sort of like the superclass type
and we have a type matching so when you
call a dine function it will try and
match the input types against the
signature and you can see here that you
know my type of fixed times T matches 12
times in 16 or my type of fix times T
does not match borrow times in 16 so
it's just a dynamic thing in the you
this is a dynamic interpret it's a
dynamic matching of the same kind that
you'd get in something like C++ or
compiled language which would check it
at compile time so we also have callable
and functional Xin dined so dine is not
just about data it's about expressivity
expressivity and compute so in diet you
can share the caller balls just
alongside data so the call was the first
class objects that can go between
languages and that's I showed an example
that earlier with this dynamically
publishing callable is using ND set so
we want people to write a callable in
one language and bring it to another so
you should be able to write a couple see
the fuss and bring it to python without
doing any extra work and we also want to
enable the creation of cobbles using
generic patterns so we have a bunch of
functionals which transform one call
bowl to another and i will show examples
of them like l wise or reduction or
multi dispatch or outer or neighborhood
all the kinds of things that you know
that fit a variety of computations and
our call was also over loadable so you
can actually define particular
operations like plus minus
multiplication divide whatever for your
own custom pipes which you can register
so here's an example of an element wise
functional in Python we use decorators
here to indicate a functional transform
and if you're going to write a call on
Python you have to specify the output
type and that is because you actually
dainese know to allocate it's a very
natural thing numpy 0 for the cases
where there is some overlap numpy also
has to do something similar it needs to
know what to allocate so you can't just
write a simple you can't just write a
Python function with no return and what
we're using there is Python 3 syntax
there's an equivalent Python 2 thing if
you don't wanna use Python the rate but
Python 3 actually supports annotations
like that using the
too and you can't recall some support
annotations on the input types but we
haven't used them there so there I've
written a simple function which returns
a float64 and it's just you know 2x plus
y minus said and if I use the element
wise decorator it will automatically
transform this into an array function
which takes any number of dimensions and
I printed out the signature here which
is the first argument comes a bunch of
dimension x a scalar the second margaret
also budgeted much time together and so
on and the last the return type is a
punch in two matches time to float as i
specified and then i can then apply this
to any sort of number of dimensions or
if I just want to you know throw Python
objects into it lists of lists or
whatever similarly we have a reduction
functional so there I'm just doing a
maximum of two numbers and returning an
n 32 and then I can apply the reduction
fractional decorator and it becomes a
little bit more complicated but not that
much though so the first argument again
just becomes a bunch of dimensions types
of scalar and then i get actually get
keyword arguments which dine supports so
we can take in a bunch of the axis over
which to do the reduction we take in the
identity element if there is one the
question marks here mean that those are
potentially optional arguments to the
function and we can take in a argument
called keep dims which is just whether
or not I want to keep all the dimensions
of size 1 these are the same sort of
things that number has and we return a
bunch of dimensions times in 32 and you
can see I can do you know the reduction
on a list of six elements and it returns
the maximum and below I pass and a
keyword saying hey I want to do is
reduction the maximum but use the 101 is
the identity and then I get 101 back so
it's just the point here is that with a
single line of code you can get very
simple array computations that of the
kind you want and you can use any for
something like element wise you can use
any number of arguments we can also
write multi dispatch functionals and
here's a simple example and while they
dispatched by the way if you don't know
is when you just want to write something
which has different behavior for
different types
so an example would be something like
the gamma function which is a function
used in science engineering and what's
special about this is that on integer
values it reduces to the factorial so
but if you don't have an integer value
it's much more complicated so here just
the throw up a simple example where I
written a factorial function and a gamma
function so the factorials for integers
the gammas for real numbers I can then
use dines functionals to sort of stitch
them together so totally different
behavior but you want the abstraction is
this but under the same abstraction so
then once you've stitch them together
you'd have to think about it you can
just call it and it'll branch depending
on what's going on and then on top of
that I've put it into the element-wise
decorator so I will apply this across
any number dimensions so this crease the
cobbles just it takes in a single array
returns a single array of any number
dimensions of any scalar and I can apply
that to various kinds of data and it
does the computation as expected so for
integers I get integers back using the
factorial for floats I get floats back
seat in the gamma function option
operations so again like for missing
data you can just show here that we
already support the built-in operations
I'm missing data so I can you know add a
non missing value to a missing value and
you will get either propagation of
missingness or skipping depending on
sort of keyword values and what
operation you're doing so in the second
example there I'm creating a missing
data and subtracting a array of no
missing data and I get missing this
propagator appropriately so on and so
forth for the rest and a very cool
feature of dined which I haven't talked
much about today is that because we
support things like a variable-length
arrays and because these were things
like strings well and because we support
these things like struck so we can
actually very natively represent JSON
like data so i can create you know
ragged strokes of whatever and then i
can do operations on it which are simply
impossible in numpy or many other of
sort of similar solutions so here I've
created a
list so I have three people Alice Bob
and Charlie they each have some credits
so and I want to know who is sort of
like in debt so what this is is a
variable-length array it's a fixed array
of structs so strings and then within
one of the members of The Strokes is a
variable length or right so it's a bit
complicated so three strokes and inside
the struct is a variable-length array
which could be whatever its variable any
size and you see that because these guys
have different umber of credits and then
so I set up that data and that i can
very naturally do the same sort of
computations that might want to do in
numpy but on this very exotic data set
which is I just want to know who's out
of money so I'm going to some the
credits and i'm going to ask which is
lesser than zero and I want the name and
in one line I can get that very easily
in this case is both Bob and Charlie so
I'm actually out of time now so that's
that's good because I'm finish my talk I
want to thank a few people so the core
contributors which is me mark Wiebe Ian
Hendrickson and Stefan craw all of whom
are excellent all of whom come from very
different backgrounds and we also have a
number of other people to to thank also
on that continuum kingdom is very
graciously but funding this project and
many others and you should check out all
their stuff including many of things I
just mentioned and yeah I also want you
to try dine dine is still you know a bit
experimental it's certainly a lot less
experimental than it used to be so I'm
not going to say you know everything
works smoothly but I think you can do a
lot with it now and I encourage people
to play around encourage people to use
kada to install it that well that should
work and yeah and thank thanks for
listening how do we store strengths
right so we have two strings types one
is a fixed ring which same is numpy so
that kind of makes sense yeah and the
other one we it's a pointer and a size
with a special optimization for small
strings which where we saw them in line
so we store an array of pointers and
sizes so for each string there we have
pointer and a size but if the string is
can fit into the combined bytes of that
pointer in that size it will do so
there's a small optimization for that as
similar to what things like spark uses
yeah
right so right so that's a good question
so so to speak to arrow and feather so I
think I almost had a slide on something
like this but then decide not to do it
but so I think there are sort of two
projects which are if you want to say
what is similar to dine I would there
two things I would list one is Julia and
11 is yes arrow and feather and I'm you
know touch on both of these right now so
Julia is a whole language and I think if
you look at sort of an obviously much
broader scope much more mature much more
contributors and I'm clear dying is sort
of like I think Johnny Julia share a lot
of the same philosophy and all the same
underlying design with the type system
with regards to how they treat a race so
I think there are a lot of similarities
there which is interesting for Aaron
feather that is a data frame specific
approach so if you want you know and
actually like arrow also doesn't
actually have any compute so that's
another difference so we we we r compute
Travis yeah absolutely so that is you
know you could one could and the sort of
the point of something like that shape
and dined is that we want people to be
able to write types which can represent
all kinds of data and a narrowed out of
shape would be something very natural to
do so i would so arrow doesn't have any
compute and it's only for data frames so
if you have something which is not data
frame it just doesn't that's not a thing
it does yeah so don dime mass is more
general yeah
yeah so the numpy implication is
actually pretty good and when in fact
Stefan craw who works in this is the
buffer maintainer and Mark we've also is
written a lot of numpy as well so it's
extremely good i would say to which
example factorial yep this one
right so I i I'm tractor extracted over
a few details here so and the answer is
no that's not what we're doing but so if
you write your call you can write your
call bowls in either C++ or Python try
than C++ then you're in C++ landa things
are great if you write them in Python
actually what we're doing here is we're
using number underneath to get it I just
haven't explicitly shown that so if
numbers present it will get that if it's
not present then yes it will do exactly
what you said but that's I mean yeah but
i mean that's that's that's what you get
from writing something in Python that's
we can't really make that I would
totally say that yes um yeah but but it
does work without number if for whatever
reason your environment were that's out
there but if you wanna write something
efficient in Python with dined yes you
should use now boat alongside you'd have
installed how did how the search speed
it says not something I've ever looked
at but it's a good good question but I
don't have an ask for you yeah yeah I
mean multi array is it's a
template-based or a library and the
point when I mentioned earlier that I
want to make is that well we may use
templates they're like a hidden level of
detail and that if youíve use C++ died
it's just like manipulating simple
dynamic objects where's boost its all
templated it's impossible to share
functions like this
so that is something we the answer is it
should be possible it's not something we
haven't gone beyond Python yet we'd like
to hit our and potentially even Julia or
jaw or node or something like that this
is not something we've got to yet yes
the idea is that is like a primary goal
and the fact that we're sharing you know
functions between C++ like all of dine
is written in C++ and then shared
naturally to python that's sort of like
an early stage proof that we can do that
do you have an idea roughly an
implementation like I say I write in my
name pipe in my work with friends of
mine during our yep it would generate
some sort of library that they would be
able to import into brett are and that
kind of thing right so the answer would
be like so i think i showed a slide
earlier on about dine plugins so you'd
write a simple plugin library which
would just be you know a shared object
library and dined if dine python is
there it will know how to deal with that
and bring your call those two design
Python if dying or is there which does
actually exist but if died or is there
then it will know how to interpret that
and bring your combos to our that's one
way to do it yeah yeah
right yeah so good questions missing
values so right now they're implemented
using central values which is the same
technique our uses so for you know every
particular type of data you have to say
this is the particular value i'm going
to use to represent messiness and there
are four missing values to be honest
there are multiple approaches and they
all like advantage the disadvantages so
the central of proteges set has some
particular advantages like it can be
more efficient in some cases but
sometimes you may want like flags and
ultimately we actually intend a smart
bolt your second question which is about
sparseness dying absolutely would be
sued a little slower for like that we
don't have a particular sparse type yet
which is probably what you'd want but
it's been you know that's one of the
things we're thinking about one or two
developers is an applied mathematician
and think about that a lot
didn't so so I would actually say that's
it's not yes of course we are making
something more flexible numpy that's
we're trying to film the gaps is what I
would like to say about that in terms of
you know whether there will be like a
lot more branching or a lot more so what
we've done is because we support we've
focused a lot on optimizing things like
multi dispatch so you can get very
quickly to the particular code you need
for your particular operation and yes
for that we have done benchmarks and
what we do there is we've actually we
actually use something like Google's
hash map library which is extremely fast
and can can you know look up something
in you know just a couple of nanoseconds
and if you're in the c++ level that is
extremely fast like I have time this an
empty function call in Python just like
lamb colon none takes like 40
nanoseconds so that's when you went into
a couple of nanoseconds is almost
negligible before the kind of
computation we're talking about we're
talking about a race it's not answer
your question yes so specifically
against nut but yes so we for something
like say a basic arithmetic operation
you would not expect to beat numpy you
should match it I mean numpy would be
very well optimized for that we're just
talking about adding two numbers and we
typically do magic yes and for some of
our GPU stuff we actually have
benchmarked against Pike cuda and again
we typically do match it but I'm not
saying the comprehensive but I'm saying
yes we have done benchmarks
okay great he said the best python
bindings for a c++ call is that is that
does it apply to every everything like
this is everything that you showed here
on the place that available yes yes
everything there's in fact there's
actually mourns the c++ layer that then
in Python because that's the whole point
the money should be a shell is possible
so yes bossier is a sure if I want to
send done yes so we haven't there is a
work in progress on that there is some
code it's not something that people
should use now we have an extensive
design document about how that's going
to happen and so Ivan it's well thought
out and well-planned is just someone is
sit down and finish it yeah so yes we're
a very much the thing is happening yeah
they're all open so in if you go to the
dime git hub which is or just go to the
lib down org which thanks to everything
you'll find links to this and in our on
our repository we have like a dev docs
folder all out so we have a lot of good
design docs are some slightly slightly
out of date but because you should the
multi dispatch well I feel on this one
so basically you have a multi dispatch
that's right exactly and then we figure
out how to I mean if things can be
brought you know just straight forwardly
to python we do that and in some cases
we might change the syntax a bit to make
it more natural with the particular
language because i want python users to
you know feel like the writing python
for instance
there is no more question then